podcast special guest in here detroit is
in the building
the red zone to be specifically in the
west at and the west side okay all right
been to both sides uh recently uh we got
uh my guy skill a baby and of course
shot a baby in the building welcome
welcome welcome fellas what up dog
hey man um break down the east side west
side [__] because back in the day
it would always feel like there was like
tension between the two sides from like
an outsider's perspective it feels like
nowadays it's very a lot of everyone's
kind of just moving in the same
direction is everybody [__]
everyone's [__] yeah
that's just what it is [__] got
cousins on the east side because on the
west side when you cross woodward that
separate east and west
it was like a big thing because like you
feel me like
you know some some west side [__] was
scared to go on the east side some i
wouldn't say scared but you know you got
comfort zones right so then with
i guess
it takes like one or two people to do
something and be comfortable on the east
side or the eastside
our way it's just
like us
like and he can say the same statement
and say he's he's covered he's had
[__] or a few he's out and he's scared
to go west they ain't really scared
they don't [__] with the west side and
then west had now followed each other
ugly i ain't gonna read this ain't
nothing to put me over there that part
like
if you find something like say like if
you go like to like a suburb or detroit
like you got people like you got people
in like utica that ain't never been
detroit right but you would think like
it's a whole bunch of black people
that's that been detroit you would think
anybody around there been to detroit
before but you're running to a black
person that's from utica or something or
or even like troy and they'd be like i
don't got a reason to go to night
but like far out places like muskegon
and [__]
yeah i got home he lives out in troy
there's radio out there but i don't
think he's ever ever been cause he don't
got no reason right
when you when you think about detroit if
you're not from there you're gonna think
it's rugged yeah everybody gonna tell
you it's violent which it is but it's
violent everywhere you just gotta know
what you're doing and where you're going
that'd be that's kind of the main
takeaway i probably took because i was
out there for a week i was like you know
i feel like uh everywhere has got their
issues
but like i [__] loved it out there
it's fun everybody was super cool i mean
the food was great the people were chill
and i was like i like i i don't
understand the um
i mean that's the best like he said it's
violence [__] happens everywhere
everywhere
it happens here people get robbed on
melrose here you know what i mean like
so i feel like um
it's dope too because i feel like right
now detroit's pretty much i feel like
it's like detroit and memphis you know
really got got the culture right now you
know yeah um how did you guys link up um
we got family mutual families people
were [__] [__] like
[Music]
it's like i grew up with his little
brother though i grew up with his little
brother okay i had been homeless and
slept in the house with his little
brother like all type of [__] like this
this
i
like one of his closest friends i grew
up like he was like one of my older
brothers like wanted somebody else like
was around he looked out for me and so
it was just like a whole bunch of [__]
though like we always run into mutual
family members and friends and [__] i'm
still running the same circle yeah i
didn't realize uh you and uh baldy james
were cousins until we were hanging out
in detroit and he was shooting dice in
the house we're at and i was like you
guys are going to work together he's
like he's my cousin bojic
shout out to baldy james man big bap no
that's cuz for sure he
he's the first [__]
from
like my knowledge as far as
doing something
that was indeed
with the music from he said you know
what i'm saying which was when he was
signing the nas right he was on mass
appeal early on yep
yeah that's like he did that when
a lot of [__] were super well
known now
didn't even have
three percent of the buzz or wasn't even
rapping per se you feel me so yeah he a
legend us and he's still doing big [__]
being a part of his health yeah you know
what i'm saying the nba leather tour
all the [__] he do with alchemist you
know what i'm saying that's that's bro
yeah uh my [__] baby this is
technically this is the second time
you've been on the show side of baby
yeah i know so the first episode didn't
come out though i don't remember that
because look he told me he's look i bump
it to him right he's like [__] i was
gonna drop the other interview but [__]
you was on that [__] sleep
i said brother i don't even remember
doing the interview well what happened
was you were like yo i want to come on
your show i was like well you you did
i was like
you did but i think it was maybe at a
maybe a darker time of your no i was
sipping lean you were on the lane yeah i
was sibling almost so
that day whenever day when i came and
did the show i probably that was
probably one of the days i overdid it
you definitely overdid it you were
definitely nodded out here yeah it was
it was i was like you know what i'm not
going to put this out see you you're a
real ninja turtle for that yeah i just
so you know i i don't i'm not into uh
you know it's a moment of vulnerability
man you know what i'm saying and i'm not
i went to sleep i wouldn't sleep on vlad
interview he uh
he put it out but he ain't really put
the parts out when i was asleep but
anybody who watched interview you could
tell i was [__] sleep like i was i
was knocking off the whole damn time but
he was asking me some [__] too
though
what was like one thing he asked you
that kind of was like come on dude were
you like this is something this is some
black [__] [__] i answer yeah
he asked you like like three four things
i wouldn't answer you just about every
random beef you've ever had and man [__]
like that and and and what's the what's
to this [__]
and i just look over at my my my
publicist and
mike as like
i just look back at blood like
would you do his show again
yeah
i don't got a reason to yeah
i feel like i did it because it was the
[__] that [__] do you feel me get you
a flag interview i got my blair
interview it's out the way yeah you know
what i'm saying like i let out some [__]
you've heard me say some [__] that's
that's stuck and all that type of [__]
like i i introdu um i tell [__]
when i start uh gangbanging you feel me
i'm glad y'all and that [__] stuck
around for a minute so there's some
positives to it
um
talk about sada like uh
you uh not like obviously the label is
booming but
you know shout out to uh miles turner
wait miles turner miles bridges miles
turns on the pacers miles bridges on the
hornets who is uh
bisque one of the best
rapper slash ball players we've seen in
a long time
he's the best rapper he's the best
nba rapper in the league right now do
you think he's better than dame lillard
music wise yeah i think he's making
better music for sure music wise yeah
like damn it dan dolla is a is a lyrical
hip-hop head
you know what i'm saying he's more about
the bars you not gonna expect dame to
drop the type of [__] he dropped and he
really can rap you feel me like he a
real dear rapper miles bridges you can
play [__] in the club miles bridges is
gonna make the whole shake that ass
you know what i'm saying and that's what
the young [__] and the [__] want to
hear you feel me yeah [__] who really
respect music
wanna hear damn you know what i'm saying
and i
like
i know i've listened to the cds you feel
me but
skiller probably listens to damn city
you know what i'm saying
you see i'm saying i don't know i mean
listen shout out to damian lillard i
don't know anyone who's there no i
[__] know what it is i've seen his
freestyles
listen to him freestyle though listen to
him on
i just haven't like tapped in with his
albums no that ain't really like a [__]
homeboy though like [__] like i know
it's people from sabrani all that type
of [__] like that's really my [__] so
i got music with that
so like it's like and then like i ain't
going to take it away from him and say
that he don't really respect music
because i know for a fact skilling where
the [__] really live and respect music
that's why you record as much as down
there i record you feel me probably the
same amount if not more sometimes you
feel me
it's just
the type of music that dollar putting
out or will put out is not the [__]
that's going to catch his ass right but
if we scrolling on instagram like he
said like [__] yeah he's stopping
watching you know it's like you will
watch a battle rapper battle rap but you
ain't gonna go listen to his music
i like him bar for bart on the radio i
want to hear him freestyle like
i want to hear that there's a lot of
people like that especially on the
battle side i feel like a lot of battle
guys that
are aren't great at uh actually making
records only one of them [__] made a
good song
calico
and i [__] with i [__] with uh i think
sue's dope
i like that um 2 a.m madness or some
[__] that's so surprising straight
little album
i [__] with this car 2am sue and uh
mozzie did a joint album that was dope
they did too right
um
but did you see the controversy of miles
posting the cup of pink lemonade
is when you see something like that
because it was being limited i'm sure it
was but he's there's a big bag that's
pending right now for him yeah as you
kind of being like the big homie like
i taste him yeah i'll text him like hey
man even though it was just pink
lemonade you gotta understand listen on
god in heaven that's exactly what i said
i'm like [__] what you doing posting
pink lemonade brother
yeah for what like for what bro why
fumble the bag
whoever in your coach whoever your close
friend
everybody in your coach fans don't want
you to win for one but whoever your
close friends that you don't be around
daily or that you don't fully trust
and especially no hugs bro you got to
take them out of there bro and not even
play around with your close friends like
that because
a [__] gonna do what they did i
know he i know he didn't post pink
lemonade on his [__] regular story
he's probably put in his his close
friend [__] he put it in his close
friends i don't think he should have
posted it but get off my boy back
everybody get off my boy [__] you feel
me it's pink lemonade oh i think you do
i just i just know how you know how it
is man there's a he's he's a dude for a
bag like right now he'd do it for the
back and he gonna get that bag and he
young and he's gonna take her back he
wanted to post a pink lemonade if
anybody else posted some pink lemonade
that was a bum ass [__] in the league
they would let him post pink lemonade my
man's about to get a bag get off his
back they wanna try to [__] it up yeah
get off his back you feel me he i don't
think he should have posted pink
lemonade but if he got that right like
that's one of his rights so
yeah it was pink lemonade get off his
back we're talking about you with the
lean and you quitting what was a kind of
like a tipping point for you where you
decided like you know what you know i
know you like to have fun you know what
i'm saying but like
for you and specifically your personal
use what made you kind of step away and
and and as they would say kick the cup
that [__] cost too much it's expensive
yeah yeah
yeah
that should cost too much that's what i
was telling juan i ran into one and you
at the uh chordae album release party
yep
and i was like i hadn't seen one in a
minute and i was like bro sonic i'm
telling you this to your face
i think you got you got likes i know you
just dropped the record with snoop but i
think i either told you this or or told
uh one in detroit i'm like you got like
snoop potential in terms of like your
personality
your influence your like
like in 30 years from now you should be
in commercials because you're such a
lovable dude and i feel like um
sometimes you know it's it's hard to not
let the demons get in the way of like
your your your fullest potential you
know what i'm saying so i feel like
lately i feel i've been noticing like
you're just
more present if that makes sense i do
they do
do i
hesitate to [__] and not beat
her off to drink
me purposely like
i still this is a lot of situation
scenarios i was into where i was
standing on my business you feel me
while i was half dog [__] but it's
easier
to [__]
let's try to slip through the cracks not
be tired right you feel me
because i'm already just a
sleepy ass [__] all the time you're
hard working man you gaming you're
[__] hooping you're recording i mean
well as long as i stay up you think i
wasn't sleepy as [__] so like when i
finally when the times i do get to go to
sleep i'd be knocked the [__] out yeah
but yeah just as far as just making
myself sleepy from sipping all damn day
because i wouldn't
i wasn't just like
sipping because it was cool like i i
really was [__] getting hot every day
simmering a whole lot of [__]
it's too much when you when you quit it
was hard to because i you always hear
that people go through withdrawals like
schoolboy q had talked about that like
was that something that was like the
harder part to get through
yeah the second body getting used to not
being on it the first
the first like monitor was rough as hell
because i still was on the ship and all
that type of [__] but i couldn't call
turkey though i ain't gonna re i ain't
gonna rehab or no [__] like that [__] i
just stopped drinking absolutely and
drinking [__] burners and taking
pepto beers more for the whole two
months i was kicking it and then i was
straight after that yeah lean is so
expensive that they're bootlegging it
now well they've been bootlegging it but
that [__]
that's just too expensive it's just
still too expensive it's just it's too
expensive
it's crazy because like when you think
of lean and you think of like uh even
pills right they're so expensive i think
that's why we know so many people who
ended up going from that [__] and they
really get fiended out and then they end
up [__] with heroin because the
shit's way cheaper
easier to get way cheaper and then you
end up [__] you know
overdosed on on tmz or something hey man
leave this [__] alone you know what i
love that when i was in detroit went to
the liquor store and they had the uh
the bootleg weed bags for sale for a
dollar a piece so you could buy like
cookies bags you could buy runts bags
just empty bags thanks
say put your bushy weed there and sell
it
and it's funny because when i handed you
my uh i brought you some wheat from la
and you you sniffed it and you were like
i'll i'ma let you know if this was grown
in california some [__] basement out
here
for real
because i mean
you let one [__] see
[Music]
you um one [__] see your girl
operation and then
everybody think that growing up yeah
another botanist
facts
like bro you got an a in botany class
yeah i got green thumb so
you gotta watch that [__] because it'll
be some [__] with the smell on it he'll
tell you he you know he ain't smoked in
a minute but you know what the [__] we
smell like
it'll be some [__] that that look like
it's it
but then you smell it and it ain't it
there'll be some [__]
don't look like [__] but smelling it
might be it then it'd be some [__]
there's smell like it's it and then you
break it out and blow it and it's nice
you gotta blow all that [__] to know if
it's it right now
that's real i think uh sometimes we uh
put too much uh
thought into
the nose as opposed to like when you
smoke it does it get you high as [__] or
even the look cause some people don't
trim they will eat right right some
people don't let it guys just too much
relief too leafy some people selling it
before they dry like it's all
it's all factors that go in the weed
like this this [__] like you feel me
just like anything else they mcdonald's
would sell you a burger 10 years ago and
you would have loved mcdonald's but now
that everybody eat mcdonald's they get
to do all types of other [__] to it i
love it just mass producers i do too but
i'm just saying like i tired of people
acting like mcdonald's ain't guys like
they ain't grow up on it yo what up man
we gotta stop the interview real quick
to tell you about our good folks at blue
chew that's right go to bluetooth.com
fellas
you know sometimes
you go through some stress you go
through a little anxiety and your dick
is not
performing maybe how you'd like it's
called ed a lot of guys go through ed
you could just be old as [__] if you're
watching this and your dick ain't
working like it did when you were like
20. you know what i mean well listen
buchu
it is the wave uh how about this the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis getting delivered right to your
door in a chewable form in discrete
packaging and the best part about it is
it's all online
zero awkward visits to the doctor's
office zero you go online you sign up
with the promo code bootleg that's right
bootleg when you check out you will get
the first month for free all you gotta
do is pay five dollars on shipping and
you're gonna get one month's supply of
blue chew all right and you're gonna be
[__] like you were [__] never
[__] before your dick's gonna
i'm gonna assume
you're adding at least a quarter of an
inch of erection that shit's gonna be
rocked up rocked up and sucked up all
right boys so what you need to do one
more time go to bluetooth.com and use
that promo code bootleg and get your
first month for free
bootleg promo code bootleg on
bluechew.com let's get back to the
interview nah like it ain't good like
[__] it's the number one restaurant in
the world if the [__] was trash it
wouldn't be number one this [__] is
is it good for you probably not but is
it good people trying to act like
mcdonald's
is gross now and they're full of [__]
[__] them
i ain't gonna lie this is my only
problem with mcdonald's they never ice
cream never working like that
yeah middle of the night ice cream
machine you can't get a [__] mcflurry
can't get nothing
i like mcflurry with my nuggets there's
nobody who doesn't like one thing on the
menu [__] you like the hash browns you
like the sausage mcmuffin you like the
[__]
only thing
like consistently
you never had the steak bagel from
mcdonald's no i do the uh the what's the
one with the uh
you know it's got the it's got the syrup
baked into the [__]
they [__] up because during the
pandemic they got rid of all their
breakfast they had to steak um [__] with
the biscuit on it too
steak yeah it's a real steak bagel my
boy with the cheese and the sauce is
this like seasonal or is i could go and
get one tomorrow morning it's like the
sausage biscuit type [__] but they had
what's your go-to mcdonald's order
though if you had to go to mcdonald's
what is the one thing you're getting
both of you guys
i'm getting number nine two
cheeseburgers i'm getting two chickens
two mcdoubles yeah um some fries and a
mcflurry and she takes me back to high
school those dollar make doubles yeah
the dollar makes sure i gotta get a
sprite though every time i gotta get the
spice
they got the best fried in the world
they got the best spread and the best
coke they got their own versions of all
the sodas
you would think they had tried to water
it down that [__] extra strong nah the
horn remember they got rid of the orange
high c for like a year and everybody was
helping me
that orange high see hits uh you think
they try to water that [__] down though
but they [__] like extra strong you need
this sprite like this
to wash this [__] down i know but you
would think like a [__] mass producing
trying to make money like i'd be trying
to sell more of this yeah they got
better sprite they got
if you don't like mcdonald's i don't
like you for real i don't get if you
don't like mcdonald's you're a liar you
can't ask you cat that's why i like you
because you kept i'm always eating fish
fillet of fish with mag sauce
i like the flame you gotta get the
flavor fish pack i want a whole piece of
cheese guys we get the whole thing
give me the extra cheese on the flavor
fish cheese you put hey put bacon on the
fillet fish it's a
hey you said movie
bacon on the flayer fish is a movie with
the extra cheese it's it's not bad [__]
i just get the two cheeseburger meal and
then i just put all the fries
did you grow up just all the fries on
the cheeseburgers you grew up just
trying [__] from mcdonald's like oh yeah
across the street from my high school
every day at lunch we're like what are
we getting today
let's just put [__] on [__] you know
what i'm saying okay but the mcchicken
the spicy hot and spicy mcchicken and
the just the mcdouble was the classic
because they each were a dollar back in
the day
the spicy nugget from wendy's though
that's the best nugget though
you get that five for five that bag i've
been getting them [__] numbers been
good for the last two times numbers bang
in the back of my throat like my [__]
extra on fire you know what happened
when uh burger king put out
10 nuggets for a dollar and they did and
i was like i don't know if i want those
that's cardboard
i don't know if i went the dollar for
10. you know like because y'all doing
something there's something going on
there chicken ain't that cheap it ain't
that cheap
facts
hey uh sada if you had to have you know
a lot of rappers are doing meals right
now
jack harlow just put his kfc meal out
what spot would you want to meal at
that's a national chain i'm sure you got
your your coney islands in detroit you
would do a spot lobster red lobster
what would be uh
in the in the red lobster meal
everything red
just read it out yeah yeah
everything red [__] shrimp
scabby with extra [__] chili
flakes
cocktail sauce for everybody
hella cocktail sauce
that i don't um probably red lobster
though
taco bell
taco bell's
another place super gas yeah
i'm going to get six sauce tacos i just
did that the other day with the cinnabon
delights we're at taco bell
tacos they're having that random [__]
there the cinnabon then they got like
the starburst drink
one time i'm getting by high blast
though
for sure about how blessed that's second
best behind uh mcdonald's no cat
blast
i don't think they uh they still don't
tell about hot blasts at the store do
they or do they do this i don't think so
they brought because well for forever it
was just just the taco bell yeah but no
they had the [__] in the store though
taco bell's guys yeah yeah mexi milk
mexican pizza [__] because you
know we're on the west coast so everyone
frowns on taco bell because it's fake
mexican food but i'm like yeah no [__]
but it's it doesn't mean it's not good
they took them
away i don't like it
taco bell or mexican workers of course
[__] that [__] that [__] was fine
i bet you tasted just a little bit
better
and they just brought the mexican pizza
back they needed to take the french them
loads of grillers i used to get it
i just i just love the innovation of
taco bell nacho bell grande it's always
it's came with some new [__] too nacho
fries with the white cheddar cheese
always new [__] like they always just
it's always new [__] it's like they got
some dude high as [__] at their [__]
headaches
[Music]
if you ain't never been had ain't no
food bro you don't know what food tastes
like hmm what's the best uh drug to eat
on that makes that way
yeah yeah i think a lot of times
he's crazy
there's no such thing huh what i've
never done lean so i can't i'm lost too
yeah listen like you'd be full because
of all soda no
hey
brother everybody is getting fed off
lane though but [__] be eating right
before you do all
yeah you'll see the guys with the lean
bellies you'll be like i see it they've
been drinking [__] orange soda for
about seven years what i really do is we
i don't smoke weed no more but that's
good why'd you quit weed i really had to
but i didn't like they don't drop me for
weed but i'm kind of on probation but
like i ain't ripped down dropped me for
weird i really just like are you like do
you feel better now like do you feel
like i don't need it like i don't need
it yeah i get a lot more stuff done like
i was smoking weed going to sleep all
day like
pulling up here i'd have been asleep all
that type of [__] like that babies too
but your papers allow i mean you guys
are in detroit it's uh it's recreational
no you still ain't no i still tell you
it has no normally on papers but i
absolutely can't smoke
that's good she
needs to be heard have you guys ever had
any bad uh
edible experiences where you ate ate
weed and it went beautiful one time
and it drove like i was drinking out the
mcdonald's water fountain with my hands
i don't know that sounds about right
edibles
it's the worst [__] ever i was too hot
ain't nobody bro that's not no fun bro
yeah that [__] not fun
like bro why why why y'all keep on
trying to get people these [__] bro
like [__] that's a fun hat or something
terrible
all the way down they put you in a coma
house i don't even know how i got it
dirty high school
it tastes good
how to make it to where you can't taste
it
yeah in phoenix there still 9 056
milligrams of [__] weed oil and your
[__] lobster tail [__] off two bites
[__] yo [__] facing the plate yeah i
ain't [__] with the weeds yeah i
drugged my party before though you
drugged your party yeah i didn't tell
him he was reading the food
so everybody who was here at my party
yeah it was like like three years ago
it's kind of like that episode of uh uh
[__]
franklin saint what the [__] i can't
think of the name of the show snowfall
oh you gonna see
so everyone came and they ate all the
food and then progressively through the
night and it was blown and [__]
started leaving after the hour an hour
later she kicked in [__] [__]
plucking off in that [__] did anybody
freak out no
because you know if you're eating you
eat weed it can't get back i just
thought they was [__] up from the
content because i had like free blunts
and [__]
it was in the air
that's [__] great
i'm just watching it from the corner oh
that's amazing that's actually not a bad
idea if i ever next time i do like no
it's safe i didn't overdo it like it was
like yeah like safe amount of weight
right and it's weird yeah i do that [__]
with shrooms though have everyone no you
can't do that just bugged out tripping
balls at the same time it'll be like the
wedding on [__] snowfall
i told you i told you what i said when
you do um psychedelics what they say
i know
you can't do that brother you can't they
off the
mushrooms by my damn self so i can just
imagine me [__] eating some [__] with
shrimps and then it should taste good i
just keep eating the plate
when you had uh your deep shroom
experience was it therapeutic
i was stupid i couldn't stop laughing i
like this [__] i know what that's like
kept smiling
yeah
mushrooms aren't as visual as people
think they are that's like lsd acid is
super visual
so shrooms is like more things get like
the lights get a little more crazier you
know
what the [__] was mark
in miami was it shrooms when he was in
the bathroom running from the dragon oh
so he was he wasn't on trooms he was
probably on uh either dmt or lsd or he
better had to take some of that
all that [__] he was wet
oh he
let's talk about big wayne off that perk
in miami oh big wayne off the presser
look you ever seen a whale
yeah i mean fresh out of the water
yeah like need the water but needed to
live
threw up on the dice game i'm like yo
this big ass wheeled up man it can't
handle nothing
nothing south side from 808 mafia uh
was here the other day
and he was uh he was off of two perks
during the interview and then explaining
perks like having sex on perks to me and
how it's kind of like
it's like its own thing like perk sex is
better than regular sex for the for the
girl i guess
i don't know what it is
like it's like kind of like some viagra
type [__] oh but volition
charge the battery
that's for these old [__] though
oh yeah
i ain't doing no perky sick no no no
[__] back in you guys
have you ever done the honey pack or the
blue rhino with the gas station no i'm
scared of those shut up about that blue
right over but i already packed it down
for sure the honey pack is serious back
in i think if i do some [__] like that
cause i'd be having a whole bunch of
crazy girl drama so
they're gonna be even more sprung if you
[__] take a vitamin oh [__] like that
yeah that's oh [__] [__] no it's not
it's not anymore
not anymore by the way go to
bluetooth.com right now
cause i was [__] 16. use the promo
code blue like first month free at the
same time if you have of 16 they can
take eat pills and drink a hell of
liquor trying to charge that battery oh
yeah ain't nothing like that
you've never been so drunk that you have
like whiskey drinks
in your life i don't be drunk for real
like in your life you've never gotten
before you're weird i'm lame did you say
you never [__] one two and three hurt
[__] you
did you say that you've never [__] a
[__] off of pure will before hell no
not not i only only [__] like i [__] one
[__] i like off for a long time off
your wheel you forgive me other than
that i wake up
yeah [__] since i was 16 when i [__]
around the ditty by accident i was off
hell of drugs
[__] and drunk and i [__] the [__]
for like three hours i'm like yeah i
know that wasn't just me that's not
normal you feel me something they got
their ssdn yeah we
something else and something else
sometimes like i'll go down i'll go to
mexico and get the generic violence oh
[__] you know some freaky ass old names
i ain't gonna lie
my moana is a drink it's a it's like a
wine drink that they they say it's uh
they call it
his house it's like wood in it yeah
it's a dominican aphrodisiac it keep
refilling drink
that [__] keep refilling yourself for
something bro it's wood so if you go to
if you ever go to like a dominican
resort yeah it's like it's like a it's
like if you were to go to mexico and
they gave you corona or tequila it's
like they're in the dr mamawana is like
a
it's like a it's like going to [__]
detroit going to a coney place you know
what i'm saying it's very fun
so it's it's a wine
wood and [__] and then they pour it and
it's it's it refill itself or some [__]
and that shouldn't get you [__] up but
there's definitely
[Music]
they say like they should get you [__]
up though
you ain't had nothing i ain't drinking
that [__] why not
i don't i'm not trying i'm scared to get
that high i don't really want to do that
no your dick's gonna be hard you're
gonna be drunk no i don't like drunk
that ain't my type of thing most people
can't hide like i don't really like
driving have you ever been so high you
can't [__] off a weed no hell no i don't
know i'm just asking i ain't never not
been able to [__] unless i ain't like
the [__] hmm i'm dead
okay what about have you ever like liked
a [__]
but got to the point where you're about
to [__] her for the first time and that
[__] stinks
but it's stank yeah yeah i'm kicking
that [__] out you you got to kick her
out right yeah you've never i ain't bi
so you've never been like
man we already here no i didn't i didn't
have this though never pulled one of
these doggy styles yeah i didn't i just
had this though i didn't [__] [__] was
stinking and then i got in her [__]
out of nowhere she got a period i don't
know but that [__] had to go no cat
that [__] was i don't think anything
smells more than [__] a chick on her
period
you like you do that
of course i mean i'm married
i'm married
you run red lights huh yeah i run red
lights yeah i ain't doing that
we like uh uh i got my wings i got my
red my my red wings for sure yeah what
you do is you have the red towel on deck
or the dark colored towel like a black
towel
so you skipping it you have the towel
down
and then then the towel doesn't stay so
so you skipping around the hole and you
eating it you licking the cleat so oh
i've eaten my wife out on her period
i have but
but what you just described i wasn't
like in the [__] no that's what it is
you gotta do you gotta not eat the
bloody part you gotta you just like the
clip i ain't did it yeah it was uh it
was uh well i know what the beast wanted
it was like the day after i proposed to
her we were in vegas bad time and she
got her period and i still ate around he
was drunk
no i was sober oh cause if you were
drunk you might have slipped
yeah i was sober i didn't give a [__]
i might have had some i might have some
blood on my chin
we did
we did it was uh there was like a tub
and a shower it was a suite in vegas
yeah now it's my wife
shout out to my wife
i i just can't do it but i teach i don't
listen i don't prefer to to have sex on
a period for sure like i prefer not to
do that but
i'm saying i have
he said he had blood on his chin
[Music]
so i propose to my wife and then that
next morning we drove to vegas and then
she got her period so it was like we
were in a very romantic mood we had a
suite and i was like well listen we're
in vegas so you did that oh a week
yeah for a couple days yeah
one cup i didn't cut the lights on and
it was blood and yeah but i ain't never
willingly [__] up and it looked like a
murder scene you're like damn are you
squirting like oh no it's blood
yeah cause you ruined your [__]
sheets it's over pizza ruined my [__]
life for a couple weeks for days to a
week [__] [__] blocked and everything
that's right all right
hell yeah never talking to you again so
she got her period and you're like [__]
you in nature you're out of here no this
is my thing you supposed to know that
you're about to happen or something
you're about to warn me
so like you know i'm about to come on
[__] knock it down you located he
could have caused the period i just did
that that's cool i just did that listen
if i did that all right but when these
lights come on [__] i'm not about to be
happy by looking at no blood [__] you
gotta go i'm i'm mad blocking you out of
here
it depends on how cold she is for me you
should pull it up if you on on
on on that time
it's close to that like if it's close to
that you feel me like i ain't going i
ain't gonna block her but i'm a hungry
for show every time that happened
knowing she might come on up here and
i'll knock it down and don't tell me
new comforter new sheets i need all that
or i'm blocking you you have to go to
the store right now go to target re-up
the whole [__]
it's like a murder scene when you when
you wash off after that huh you look
down and you saw me
then you got to go home and check out
what you really got to do
yeah like if she ain't noticed that
she's bleeding just stick it in her
mouth real quick
you're terrible it tastes like metal
yeah you got a stick you gotta stick it
in her mouth
like yeah [__] it tastes like pennies
i'm saying though if she ain't if she
ain't tell you she is bleeding as soon
as you figure out she bleeds stick it in
her mouth oh did you taste that you
taste that yeah did you taste those
pennies [__] you're bleeding hey look
she ain't even look
hey look she didn't even see the blue
yeah you just stuck it in our mouth
you're [__] up
you ain't tell me [__] i ain't gonna
tell you easily that's terrible
because it's in the door
oh hey if i'm traumatized you're gonna
be traumatized we're both gonna we're
both leaving here traumatized
jesus
but that depends on if i don't like you
though like if i don't like you right if
it's just some chick
popping in her mouth you play with me in
detroit what is the uh best
strip club for food
because we went to a place called uh
there's a bunch of ugly juggalo looking
[__] dancing
pantheon
coliseum oh y'all
it told us to go there
no comment but y'all y'all gotta
tell y'all to go there yeah all right
because we went in there and all the
[__] were ugly they were flat white
women who look like they just left the
technical
truth the food was terrible you got to
go to a space everyone was saying truth
but i don't i think that they were like
a little nervous to send us the truth
like by yourself
i'm fine i'm like or ace of spades i
went to ace of spades that's on the west
side
that was where mazzy was at a couple
weeks ago
little blades
party like if truth ain't slapping ace
of spades slapping a spade ain't
slapping true slippers
don't wear the big booty finance black
girls girl you feel i may or may not
have seen him
the food would be hitting miss it's
really
the chef you gotta kiss the right [__]
like
where's john p working there right now
no he might he might be at typhoons
though
that tycoons whatever they should call
it baby yeah i think he went to tycoon
bro i loved it i was saying this earlier
i said i love i've been telling
everybody i'm like yo i'll go back like
tomorrow that [__] was dope i love the
experience i love the food the people
were cool
i mean we're there a whole week it's fun
yeah that's what i was telling him i'm
like bro like at the end of the day if
you're a scared-ass [__] like go
somewhere else be scared there you know
what i'm saying like
but it's a hood everywhere and the [__]
that happened everywhere 100 and i i
felt like uh
just everywhere i went um we went to the
east side the west side we went
everywhere and it was just to me it was
like
it was just kind of refreshing man it
was like normal people we live in l.a
you know [__] are weirdos now
not in la now obviously
we are in north hollywood this is where
all the artists and the producers and
the actors move this is the p like it's
just a bunch of [__] getting
like uh
you know 11 item starbucks orders over
here you know what i'm saying it was
nice to be in detroit and i uh i was
telling him i was like man i feel like
the national narrative is definitely
misleading but i think it's because like
when you're in detroit we know what's
going on so it's only probably like out
of honey things that happened probably 5
10 was just random and then the security
guy like empire for the first day got us
a security guy and i felt like he was
like trying to scare us bad so we like
would have hired him for the rest of the
trip
and i was like no i think we're gonna be
fine what was he doing he was like yo
don't go here you can't go there without
me remember that
that's like anywhere we were like yeah
we're gonna go here he's like you can't
go there without me i'm like
i think we'll be all right like
like
it's not it's not too much we were like
gonna go to greek town he's like don't
go to greek town
i was like
he's like don't go there he tripping
he's like you gotta go there with me he
tripping he tripping
trippy nice he was a nice guy he looked
like a shamar more what was his name
remember security guards dave he's a
nice guy you he was he came to that
house that day
i forget his name you remember his name
cyrus
moore you look like shimon more from
schwab nice guy though
super nice guy shout out to him
[__] getting their head busted at the
crib for a reason and ain't just
randomly
doing
we got i don't
know school shooters at the crib or no
[__] like that like that [__] not
happening [__] doing some hoe [__]
somehow [__] happened to him
how do you feel uh well sorry let's talk
about the gaming [__] because you were
kind of explaining to me a little bit a
couple of weeks ago about some of the
gaming stuff that you have coming
i just saw you been posting uh the the
gaming rig is serious customized
my pc your pc is serious boy uh what
exactly you got going on because i know
you're not you're a big gamer man so
tell me about everything you got going
on in that space i just
launched my own twitch channel the bag
the big ape gaming you feel me some [__]
i've been doing without streaming for a
while with a couple of my mexican
homeboys they about to pull up [__]
is they them here yet
yeah but no they they coming out here
from arvin and [__] bakersfield and
[__] but um
it's just i'm i'm a big 2k [__] you
feel me i've been playing 2k online
competitively for like the last four
years and then got good at it and seen
all these other people make money off of
playing a video game so as much as i
play the game like lebron tell you he
just be in the streets a lot like
i have him on the game with me for four
to eight hours i'm gonna be on there you
feel me when he was playing the game is
2k the go-to or you do that's my go-to
game i played i played anything though
ain't no [__] are you playing like call
of duty
fortnite all that [__]
ain't no [__] i play 18.
that's fair i play everything i don't
mean i'm the sweetest at that [__] but
in the new 2k well the newest 2k i'm the
[__]
what's your go-to team though no we
don't play we don't play you got your
custom team that you built right the car
player oh play oh that's right the
player [__] yeah so you play my position
i play shooting guard oh that's what
i've been playing for okay if you're
picking a team though who's the team if
i'm playing fast yes i wouldn't be able
to tell you because i don't play it i
won't play you're just with your built
guy that's it that's where that's that's
where they're feeling at you ask him
what's more fun
my son myself that's how my son plays
it's like playing with virtual you or
playing with these [__] that i i
really want to watch on tv
[__] them [__] i'mma play with virtue
with me and act like i'm in the league
with these [__] and yeah they
if i was six seven that's how i'd be
hooping ah holy [__] you feel me what uh
cuz you know with twitch there's a
there's a lot of money there yeah i get
it i gotta get affiliates first
you gotta become you gotta become a
twitch affiliate right yeah i ain't got
my affiliate [__] but i'm on the way to
it you know who does really well uh
playing just random [__] just being
himself is t-pain t-pain's killing it on
twitch man you guys should do some sort
of collab
if i if he's got nappy boy gaming you
got big ape gaming mm-hmm
i might have been with my boy next time
you're in atlanta just go to his house
i'll have you on the twitch tell me i
just go to his house yeah just i'm sure
if you out connect you guys yeah you
might have an i like my boy but yeah i
ain't just pulling up on me um this new
record with snoop dogg is fire
uh
well how did you and snoop link up like
that's gotta be a cool did y'all
assuming you ended up at the compound
no
it was off a whole lot of choppers and
he [__] had posted a video or some
[__] like that and i reached out to him
through the dm and she sent his number
and we [__]
uh kicked it for a second and [__] i
asked him to do a song and he said shoot
it over
so [__] i did the song sent it and yeah
send it back and like
if it wasn't the same day it was like
within a day or two some [__] like that
that's fire yeah like we had it for like
um it's probably like a euro
uh a snoop somebody in detroit like you
grew up listening to because i know it's
obviously you know
he's somebody i grew up
respecting
yeah not personally this is like like
like the the first city was the doggy
style yeah that one when when he was
standing when he was sitting on top of
the doghouse yep that's like the cd i
know classic you feel me that's the cd i
know one of the best albums ever i
looked i i i knew snoop more from
like my memories from him is acting
yeah like in the movies he was in you
remember training day she like
remembered
he was in a [__] uh
baby boy of course
shout out to baby boy that's probably
the best movie
the wash
no the watch probably was the best movie
yeah you think the watch better than
baby boy yeah yeah yeah he had more
screen time yeah but i just mean better
i ain't really i'm talking about as far
as his role his role was more prominent
i like his role than baby boy because i
don't look at this he was like yeah he
was always [__]
he played it well he played it well he
played the fire he played shout out to
her ass nick but he wasn't he yeah right
yeah like i like i like snoop and train
today more than i like him in baby boy
he was in the uh world trade right
with him
that was a good line
fire ass line he had no leaks
rainy day's a good movie
fire ass movie yeah
good soundtrack too my cousins from he
was like today is they gonna [__] you up
did they did the mexican dudes
were they gonna rape the dude in that no
they're going to kill me
oh no i'm thinking of uh next friday
where they're like have you ever had
your [__] pushed in no that was that
movie that was that that oh that was
training day yeah well there's a rape
that's what that means that's a question
you asked someone you're about to think
that's a wild ass question have you ever
had your [__] pushed in what do you
think that means
it's a terrible that's a terrible pickup
line too fellas don't ever tell that to
a young lady
um i think if a [__] at the crib tell
you whoever's had your [__] pushed
that's what they were talking about is
what i'm saying
they were talking about they're about to
kill them they're like you've ever had
your [__] pushed in i say like i'm a
[__] you in the ass
that's what they were talking about no
no no
there ain't no tough [__]
it isn't anybody say that [__] what up
y'all hey we gotta stop the interview to
tell you about our partners the
presenting sponsor of the bootleg kit
podcast our family at odd socks man
they're dropping so much heat at odd
socks right now go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg kev one word bootleg kev you
will save 20 off at checkout listen they
got the socks you know what i mean shout
out to the ninja turtles uh i totally
just dropped my mic flag
and then they got the odd socks basics
which are just kind of like these boys
my favorites i love the odd socks basics
and let's not forget ladies and
gentlemen odd socks now has the
underwear that's right tapatio draws on
that ass
remember oddssoxofficial.com use that
promo code bootleg kev save 20 off at
check out let's get back to the podcast
you got a mixtape coming right
up because i just was invited to was it
makes a police
just come again
[Music]
scoops out of two way fast i think
that's what it's called
i appreciate the fact that you're not
quite sure what your own project's
called he said i think that's what it's
called it comes out friday
yeah
friday
thanks i ain't playing with you neither
i don't know the date that come up
thursday night at midnight
9 p.m pst midnight
detroit time right
yeah is it is mid is detroit it's
eastern standard right we three hours
yeah ahead of uh yeah esteem um who
all's on the project
he's on the project
are you on the project i think skill on
there um do you know if you're on there
is this skittle is this killer
song of
oh so it's a bunch of stuff kind of yeah
there's like a couple new songs in there
some [__] like that
got you because you've been putting
singles out so you just kind of put
everything on one project
get it out
i know
are you on there for sure though no cat
i don't know for sure like i think i
think fatso on there
that's another song
[Music]
are you on there yeah what are you on
there i don't know but i know i don't
know if he hunter
you're on there all right i'm on it
nice but he on the other tape though and
then the one after that and one after
that we just did a double song last
night with two intros from two people
that did that we [__] with numbers
fire i can't wait to hear that [__]
again would you guys uh
maybe i'm ignorant i don't know if this
has already happened would you guys do
like a
you know watch the throne type of album
together we got tape is called carmilla
prank but like it wasn't it wasn't
really like yeah we put our super oil
into that [__] carmilla bryant i like
that it was just [__] who's the mellow
fan
is that your guy i think you told me
that like that's your favorite player
i wear the kobe all-american jersey
yesterday fresh is full but not the
jeremy grant no
no
what'd you say on that song
you gotta go with the kate cunningham
right yeah i'll do that yeah that's cool
that was nice but i'm a being fan you
can't tell me nothing wrong about being
so you're not a not a pistons fan i know
you're a i'm a die-hard piston fan yes
that's my favorite that's our favorite
that's listen really that's your
favorite team yeah right i want to see
the pisses win yeah well i'm a sons fan
but my favorite players lebron no like
my favorite team is the lakers but my
favorite team is the pistons i don't
know what that means my favorite team is
the lakers but my favorite team is the
pistons still not sure because kobe
played for the lakers doesn't play there
anymore yeah my [__] died but
i repeat my baby but i'm still a lakers
fan i don't like brian for real like i
like brian as a person but as a player
i'm a kobe fan so i gotta hate brian you
don't got to yes i do you can just
appreciate it yes i do you can just i
feel like i appreciate his game but i
don't hate him no more but because him
and mello came out the same draft i i
had to hate him just because you feel me
i had to yeah you feel me everybody else
just liked him so much well also isn't
like detroit in cleveland you guys have
a rivalry no no no it's so close
rivalry [__] lebron was just beating
our ass [__] running a [__] rivalry
yeah
yeah yeah like this
cleveland like the cavs in the business
no
this is why people start got no results
that's why people start really hating
brian they're deep hatred for lebron for
me
when he ducked on she then he really
[__] us up the whole playoffs brian
don't even shoot threes at this point in
his career he's shooting from half court
he's super half court like bro stop
doing this [__] is his coach yeah stop
doing this like that we ain't i ain't
like him since i like them since
every sense cause we
that was like the year
we like that was like right after we won
that was the year that he went to the
finals and got swept by the spurs yeah
but this is like right after we won so
we also yeah you guys were [__]
chauncey phillips uh
friends
ben wallace
yeah that's two years after but it was
it was the year after you guys went
right yeah
because you guys went two years in a row
we went two years in a row yeah the
second year y'all lost the second year
we lost yeah
but look though i'm saying that's right
after we went right so when you guys are
playing
when you guys were playing the lakers
and you guys beat you guys beat the
lakers right you guys it was kobe and
carl malone and all them it was that
super team that didn't work were you
going for the lakers kobe or were you
going for your pistons no i was going
for the pistons i'm a real city [__]
okay so that's your favorite team not
the [__] lakers no
no
no you're like my favorite team but look
it's on some [__] like this
this is my favorite team but my favorite
player over there like but he's not
gonna wake up look i ain't wake up every
day trying to go see chauncey billets
and then play like i wanted to see
78 points in the finals i want to see i
really wanted to i really wanted to see
the pistons have a close game so chance
he could shoot a three at the end that's
what i want to big shot
and your favorite yeah
yeah like this is my favorite franchise
bosch i'm a sunset by far i like this
franchise i hate how about this i hate
the lakers but i love lebron so when he
went to the lakers i had to have like a
real meeting of my like pride and my
heart and just say you know what i'ma
put the laker hate aside i live in la
lebron's on the team and at the time the
suns are absolute ass cheeks
so i said and as long as the suns ain't
in it
i'm a roofer lebron even though he's on
the [__] ass favorite player yeah i'm a
lakers figure because milo player but
i'm a i'm a yeah he does i'm on some
[__] like you feel me brian get my [__]
ring
yes i don't know how they're not gonna
get that shanghai sharks contract
michael beasley just got
all
supposed to be in the league bro he was
nice no he still is mike supposed to be
in the league he's not just here yeah no
he was uh i remember when he came out of
college i thought he was like he wasn't
never bad in the league though like all
right i think he just had
yeah i think people just i mean he went
through a lot that dude had a traumatic
life and they say
but a lot of people hear cases a lot of
people here jaylen brown here in case
like jalen brown is [__] up mentally
i mean
yes he is
i know his dad's uh making this guy in
security guards
i think he played because of the mental
health issues and then just publicly
when did the press conference say the
[__] was trying to pull his pants down
oh dir uh i just saw that yeah [__] you
just tweaked out if i think this is
gonna win i think golden state
i hate the warriors more than i hate the
lakers because of my lebron friend i
hate the [__] warriors a bunch of
goddamn bandwagon fans that been
watching basketball since 2017 these
[__]
yeah well he's
twice he said it twice
he just said he's a chill with that [__]
that's the second time i'm saying that
[__] but this is what i'm saying dwayne
got brown in his first ring yeah it's
not even good
[Music]
they don't want to talk about that
though first of all that's not true that
is no because the first
they imploded lebron did not show up and
then the second finals
it was obviously lebron's team so dirk
nowitzki ain't exposed lebron in them
dirk nowitzki ain't exposed them yeah
and then they fixed it the next year
yeah shout out to dirk man he's an
all-time great caucasian
all-time great white man that dirk
nowitzki yes
he's on the
he's in the mountains we just had an
argument i feel like luca better though
i mean he's better as of like right now
like if you looked at the like where
dirk was in year four he's better but
career-wise
dirk's got a [__] all-time career
he's got a mvp he's got an mvp a finals
mvp and a ring i feel like look that's
coming for luca you would hope so i like
the fact luke is built like me
i feel like luca is like just like a fat
white kid with a dad bod who probably
you know drinks beer and like
he probably has like a mild porn
addiction but he gets to basketball like
i feel like
going at the end of his career gonna be
top five players ever to play basketball
i actually am not mad at that hot take
it's not a bad one because so far
you know i think like he's like a lebron
kobe type player who a uh who would you
want
you and i were kicking it the day of the
lottery and you guys ended up with the
number four pick
terrible which is the you wanted to be
in the top three in this draft but
uh but they say everybody's sleeping get
jaded ivy so i'm cool i was gonna say
who is that somebody you like who would
you want the pistons to take four to
four [__] yeah mm-hmm
bye-bye killian hayes
killian hayes that's a bust ass
terrible trash yeah yeah yeah first
round he was the first round pick right
he's like number seven number seven
we picked this [__] with number seven
we picked kelly hayes with number seven
who the [__] is would you would you
where'd he come from i don't know you
ever seen a highlight before that draft
did you know him before that draft did
you know him before draft night honestly
yes but only because i listened to a
good one i listened to uh this i
listened to
i listen to nba podcasts and there's
this dude named kevin o'connor who's a
writer who happened what was he saying
about killing him he had a hard on for
him
wow
yeah he had a super [__] hard on for
killian he still does he still talks
about all my killing hey still not done
i don't know what he can do thank you i
don't know what's like his niche
i've never seen i've never seen him get
over 10 boards never 10 assists
i haven't even seen them get 10 points
so it's like but
i mean if they like it i don't like it
but
you feel me yeah that ain't one of them
if they like it i love it they like it i
hate it yeah sada what is uh have have
you whatever ended up happening with uh
your issues with adam did you guys ever
talk is it i ain't talking but
because i feel like you were kind of a
staple over there at no jumper you were
doing the no
news e for me you feel me like with me
just was jumper
you know what i'm saying like i feel
like
like he put it in black tires he's like
maybe like we ain't friends you thought
i would go cover [__] because
you a rapper that'd be up here and when
he said this [__] i just was like rory
want to punch me on my [__] mouth but
i'm just gonna leave you alone bro and
just let that [__] right and then let it
be happy because he gonna get his karma
you know what i'm saying right like
that's all that [__] is bro
yeah it was more in terms of
you guys thought you were friends
no i thought i thought i
i i don't know what he thought i thought
you feel me yeah yeah i thought he was
my own boy
and keep on trying to talk to him
and
he keeping his disposition on [__] i'm
immediate personality i'm going to cover
and post what i want and
you mad for no reason and all this like
girly ass [__] brian bout to keep on
trying to [__] talk it out with you
shout out to a.d.a.d tried to make sure
she was straight with it
yeah it is great that's my boy yeah
that's fair um
that's cool
that's what you want stick to your guns
what uh you you mentioned there's a ton
of projects coming facts tons so
so give me a breakdown of what the rest
of the year is looking like we going to
school school
dropping [__] rru1
university yeah are you two
sophomore year and then
i was surprised
[__] wouldn't want me to do
them and the third one coming and the
fourth will come and if this [__] go how
i wanted to it would be fine it'll be a
five minute circulation all in the same
area
of the same type of [__] you feel me
same concept
over like over like two and a half three
months what about you what do you got
coming up
crack music
i'm gonna do crack news and then i'm on
[Music]
i feel like um you're you know when i
was talking to everybody out there they
kept mentioning you know you're like one
of the hottest dudes in the city man
like i i had a lot of people just kept
bringing you up like they're like you
got to tap in with skillet baby he's on
fire right now because i was like yeah
i'm going to meet with soda like you
should tap in with skillets so
um talk about just kind of like where do
you think things started to kind of go
right in terms of you like catching your
your buzz your wave
uh
i don't know i got a song going right
now ted b style of mommy versus me tape
that's really like i always been known
in the city because i'm just awesome
street [__] [__] like everybody know me
hooping this [__] but like tv style
really got me going like
farther farther than my [__] and then i
got a tape that just dropped detroit
raised and
that like hit top 50 on the apple church
so that like that kind of boosted me too
i saw um you guys had a loss in the city
the jeweler hutch which seemed to be a a
big staple out there um did you guys
have a relationship with him yeah
do you do any of your guys jewelry
yeah
like that's how i drove her that's crazy
that's like a big loss to us like we
just went to his before he got on the
plane come here we just went to his v1
for his body like that's a big loss but
that's a big lust for the city not only
is though yeah it seemed like everybody
had love for that dude yeah like and he
wanted them people that you would really
see like when you got to the games and
stuff like that you look out he um he
always got a smile on his face mm-hmm
like
yeah he's a good dude for real for real
damn
a rest in peace to him man me and my
people he was always great to us that's
dope yeah yeah
anything else coming up
from you guys um
just music and videos and videos and
music and content
content video games twitch wait what
just say what you guys say we in the
movie
movies i ain't really good at interviews
are you active or anybody first of all
you got to be in movies soon you got to
be in a comedy or something another
movie
okay so movies uh you're also your
cooking show
yeah cooking show that first episode
coming out uh calvin johnson
yeah look this is what we got covered up
he got movies coming out i got hood
movies coming out i'm starring in a good
movie it's called outside i'm working on
that right now we got merch mixtapes all
type of stuff coming where can they buy
everything give me the website
just go on your ig and just click the
link in the bio
there it is oh yeah and i'm in a movie
called get paid
you got a lot of [__] going on bro
yeah we got a lot of [__] going on
besides being confused about who your
favorite team is i'm not confused about
that this is my favorite franchise i can
tell you
all the players that play for lakers i
can't i could tell you offo pisses i
could take like the 87 pistols i'm not
about to tell you all the players that
played for the pistons i don't know that
i know
everything about the language about
chris mim
chris mama i don't know about that name
for real
you don't know about chris mim no he was
part of the 82 point game that kobe 80
was 81 or 82. see i'm 81 right 81 yeah
82 you know chris mann there was uh
jaylen rose was against him that day
yeah the photographer was guarding him
that day he's like
that was kobe gang smush parker was on
that that was coming so much parker my
least favorite laker of all time i don't
like smush parker and if you somewhere
bro don't be coaching nobody trying to
teach them to play like you because you
wouldn't it no his feelings hurt
switch markers
yeah he said about that well they always
show that they always show that graphics
sad about a bunch of [__] he'd be
speaking on this [__]
he sing he sings that's how you know
victor oladipo sings
miles miles of bridges is obviously
signed to the label he's got music
coming
rtb real trench baby there it is man
well listen i appreciate y'all pulling
up that was fun sorry about the period
blood story i know that freaked you all
out but we got through it and uh we're
on the other side of it now guys all
right boo lakehead podcast
boom